why is it why is it degrading if men are  bad like they're better because why  would you compare me to another  supreme that's a whole different level  better men are okay okay okay okay this  is this is this is this is  men are not in the conversation when  that kind of thing like her working her  ass off and getting to that point like  to bring the man into that it's almost  like why because like why doesn't this  okay okay this is my platform this is my  this is my youtube show pipe down child  respectfully  like why does it matter like why is your  first instinct to get angry when men are  or like if we compare if we compare men  to women like they don't get angry like  why is your personality  so because they don't want to be  comfortable  i'm saying like like basketball right  man statistically in every single i'm  sorry it's not a fun reality but  statistically like like in every single  category are better than women